breaking news we can bring you and tracy  connolly now she you may remember as the  mother of the child known as baby p she  is now to be released from prison there  was a lot of controversy about this she  was jailed back in 2009 for a minimum of  five years for causing or allowing the  death of her son peter at their home in  tottenham in north london and he'd  suffered months of horrific abuse at the  hands of her partner and his brother the  spokesman for the parole board says that  they can confirm that a panel of the  parole board has directed the release of  tracy connolly following an oral hearing  parole board decisions are solely  focused on what risk a prisoner could  represent to the public if released and  whether that risk is manageable in the  community and parole reviews are  undertaken thoroughly and with extreme  care protecting the public on number one  priority